[Music]
and are you serious are you serious news
were submitted by I wanna be like you a
man sued a ten year old girl after he
got her jogging into her bike
what a [ __ ] wait wait a man she's suing
a ten year old girl cuz he ran into her
bike and got her from that get out it
how do you run in should get his legs
broken what a piece of [ __ ] do how does
that even happen how does this guy have
any balls also drive better no no he
he's jogging oh and a ten-year-old girl
hit up but he hit a girl with a car he's
the place a fancy jogging with his eyes
closed like what the hell's going on
what a [ __ ] yo yes there are folks
like that out there though cuz I
remember being a little [ __ ] kid just
learn how to ride a bicycle
woo and me and my dad were riding on the
beach you know the the longest rippln
whatever and then dude was like some
[ __ ] dick face that I accidentally
ran into right and then he's all like
getting mad and [ __ ] at me and then like
my dad for the first time I saw him
being a badass and in he doesn't know
English that well but he wouldn't like
give up and did he go like this was he
like
Oh easy there 90s 90s Asian jokes babies
Asians Wow Wow
you got a regulate dude flex those
muscles dog Gilbey's there you go flex
it up dog no but I ran into the guy
because I couldn't control you know my
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know where your kid
just learned you just [ __ ] wobble
like a [ __ ]
and you get scared when all these like
things are coming you're like oh [ __ ]
right yeah my dad was like he's just
cheated Rin
he's just children you know yeah and in
the I thought if dude now she almost
fall off the scooter
yeah we're in baby like this in [ __ ] ya
see that she held on to the throttle so
like she was losing control in the road
or both of those moments you don't know
that no I had just scooter and I was
trying to test the throttle thinks I've
never ever ridden one and I didn't know
how Center said ease into everybody
everybody ease into it going and I was
laying my brain was playing my hand let
go let go and I couldn't him until
finally I was like [ __ ] and then I break
but that was really scary I was ran into
the traffic do my girl in Hawaii did the
same thing we rented scooters but she
just like let it go like the exhaust
thing like I think God did in charge but
didn't charge for know she like
literally like just let it go what are
you doing you can't do that have you
guys wrote segways yeah that shoots a
copy it goes pretty fast dude it's like
that it's like the nerd 'mobile yes yes
it's like that air wheel but then you
have a oh yeah yeah but you get the you
get the Hat like a like the hang of it
eventually but we read it saw Matt
Venice hmm that ship it actually goes a
lot faster than you think how fast like
20 30 20 miles 30 I don't know but it
feels pretty fast after a while and
you're upright right yeah you're like
upright and yeah and if you lean back
yeah you could go like I did the same
thing that's fun yeah so this right here
you see we'd even talk about the story
about this poor ten-year-old girls get
destroyed scooters yeah so this man was
suing a ten year old girl after he was
injured when he jogged into her back
wheel he jogged into her yeah so she was
just she was riding bikes with two of
her friends the two friends were on the
sidewalks the little ten-year-old girl
was on the street they were riding
against traffic he was he was jogging
behind them but apparently so the girl
ended up moving out of traffic because
she was like keeping an eye on the
jogger behind her and apparently at one
point like she she saw that he was too
far away so she didn't think of looking
back again and so she went into the
street again where she was and that's
when he he ran into her and so he sued
her and her grandparents on the basis
that they didn't teach her how to
properly ride safely I want to break
this [ __ ] legs what does this guy
look like girl he picked on retired
grandparents elderly people I mean and
jogging too and you're behind her you do
this pose not springing down even if I
was sprinting I could [ __ ] see where
I'm going
this guy's a dumb fathers yeah so the
judge saw that too and dismissed the
case thank you baby here's a good chance
we should charge him like what are not
not on a job yeah we should we should
sue him JK should sue him let's sue him
on behalf you should put him on like a
infinite tract you know one of those
those flat has greater things at the
airport we just ride and have them jog
on that thing forever and just
bicycles allergy it's up to him that the
dog at dodge that [ __ ] I love your
Chinese punishment yes you can finally
learn how to dodge a bicycle so the bike
ahem yeah just [ __ ] those pizzas pink
and white bikes with the [ __ ] little
screaming the streamers spikes
we're gonna have [ __ ] bike cannons
just suck at shooting at him like shark
campus yeah no tricycles dude it could
be different kind of bicycles mountain
bikes [ __ ] girl bikes and
occasionally our razor scooters yes yeah
yeah but he's saying like he sued
because when he fell he injured his
shoulders oh I only like him you to get
surgery because oh shut up
I don't know man even even if that was
the case like I can never blame a child
yeah this is a dull children make
mistakes I mean people make mistakes
right and it's all about it - intention
and if it really happened I'd be so
ashamed to even tell that story
I'd be like a [ __ ] semi truck came
out of nowhere smashed into me I fell
into the ground now I need surgery but I
survived
I wouldn't ask a good story I wouldn't
[ __ ] tell a ten-year-old but girl I
hit it I stumbled and like left on the
ground like that's such a [ __ ] mate
story I would just never share it not
only is it [ __ ] made it's like everyone
knows you're the dumbass you're the one
jogging and this person is in front of
you you should you have the eyes to see
where the thought they're going that's
why the judge was like seriously you
were the one talking behind them I think
it's not her fault like you can't expect
her to constantly be looking behind her
especially she's the fact that she's a
little 10 you just be looking forward
yeah what it feels your kid how would
you react if it was your kid that yeah
you saw you saw someone huh you grabbed
a slipper a hole doing wait 35 minutes
oh but with traffic right now wait an
hour and 30 just wait [ __ ]
there's people like that they try to get
money like that yeah oh yeah
but I'd like more hurt than they are on
my neck you know when that happens dude
I wish I was like a bazillionaire
because when they're like oh my back and
I'm like really yeah yeah oh my arm
oh really you know like really like
really [ __ ] it up
cuz and it's like you're faking it right
now but let me give you real [ __ ]
pain if you're gonna act like that you
traumatize me real quick yeah my mom's
like mom be like why are you crying and
I'm like whatever right and she's like
almost give you reason to cry that's all
minority parents she gave me a reason
yes I did when I lived in Arizona I was
uh my parents had a clothing store in
Chandler and I had to take their car
because I'd go to my meeting at noon
like in there was in Tempe and I was it
was like the mother meeting was this oh
12-step meeting for my it's from and so
I was in the Mervyn's shopping center
and I was back I know goes back in the
day and there's a car in front of me it
was like a minivan like a Toyota yeah
like it was like a soccer mom like a
soccer mom the details you walk from
it's the perfect right set and then I I
bear let's say this is let's say this is
my car and this is the van I barely went
like like that and she was so
overdramatic they're like and she that's
why I know they she was like like she I
like she made me go into her van de Carr
husband and she was like oh my neck my
neck and then like she was completely
faking it you know but like I know some
pressure points and squeeze her nipples
so she ended up you know I I don't know
why I even said that I go oh my parents
are in this shopping mall and they're
like well let's go you know and then the
social they end it my mom ended up going
into the the cash register and gave me
money
that sucks cuz there is doing that thing
like oh you know I barely even hit it I
wonder what those people will do if you
actually get their neck and go back I
know that would be a place you know
you're like or get them in here naked
choke yourself yeah now I imagine if you
had that much money you have millions of
[ __ ] dollars right there like my neck
really crack here
here's [ __ ] 200 bucks there's people
like that they wait for their
opportunists they wait for these certain
scenarios they go uh although walk in
front of traffic you know have you seen
those Russian [ __ ] camera videos
where people have on their cars it's
hilarious and then guys will be like
I've seen a guy throw a bike at a car
yeah like they throw their bike and then
they go do I have a camera freak out
yeah or like those people I go to the
grocery store and they have a water
bottle and then they spill water on the
floor and then hey no slip yeah yeah
what do you think about people like this
bar you just want to kick their ass you
do yeah I think the law should be if you
do that right like you slip and fall can
your injury then what you really have to
do is get that area broken that you said
that was broken yeah oh is the
punishment yeah yeah so it's like oh you
slipped and fell dude you know okay now
you really have to slip and fall and
break your leg like people at
restaurants to put a big put glass in
their food at the end of the meal yep
negati real glass yeah yeah yeah they're
like oh my god there's a [ __ ] rat rat
poop in my [ __ ] but you planted it now
yeah now you got to sit a [ __ ] bowl
of rat poop or Halloween during
Halloween I'm sure that's happening
what do you mean like we're a kid like
we'll get the food and then the parents
might be like doing something to it and
then they they'll eat it and they go
where'd you get that where'd you get
this back here Jimmy we're gonna get
them you know it could be like that - oh
like the parents stabbed
parents like then they flip the
situation and then go wet right you get
this guy had to eat poison candy
that's poison the classic Halloween
bait-and-switch
that is the best rule ever
[Music]